uh we got richard branson going to space
oh yeah these billionaires fighting over
but you see his little [ __ ] puddle
jumper
that little [ __ ] cessna son that
little space testing was
garbage and he couldn't go to space so
he went to the top of the sky he barely
even went to space yeah yeah you really
make it a big deal
you're in space i could float okay
but now like i could float like if you
go high enough do you think the snake
charmer makes the
other guy float oh i don't know where i
was getting that
i was just gonna try to make his snake
float you know
you float by blowing the [ __ ] flute
that could work yeah it depends
come on you don't know harry potter you
don't know we're teaching you about your
coaches
[ __ ] together this [ __ ] is tight as [ __ ]
okay so i gotta just go through a mall
all right put it the right way here's
his dove coming it's like
going to space is easy we can all go to
spaces come on i'm looking right now i'm
looking right now there's a group
offices
there's a groupon i know they're going
to do in 2022
they're going to go there but are you
going to space nobody's touching elon
musk and his all right we get in you're
messing a tesla
[Music]
[Applause]
how many shares you got let's bring out
shares how many shares do you have
he's got a lot of [ __ ] how do you bought
more how many shares you have
whatever you bought i still own ten
times as much oh god
damn oh [ __ ] i'm sonny [ __ ] on your own
podcast no this is your andrew shelton's
yeah
does flagrant food oh and now he's my
son so it's okay
river to the sea from the river
to the sea yeah three palaces and green
squares yeah
okay we're going to be switching some
things up over here free palestine
podcasting we're wearing blue right now
i am wearing blue for israel oh is this
for israel
yeah that's your blue square right there
that's that is actually
israel blue right there he said he
dressed you two songs
are you wearing his glasses he said he
dressed you too son
i'm all out of energy [ __ ] you dumb
[ __ ] house son how many shares you
got
how many shares you got just say the
number bro i don't know just say it
don't say the numbers people can't see
your [ __ ] face anyway they didn't see
your big ass
350 000 worth of tesla
what do you have show me the three yeah
[ __ ] he said that's still light nah he
ain't got [ __ ]
you're a part owner though for real i'm
the level of shares i own
they yeah they send me invites to the
you know elon called you ever or
what do you get you for your birthday
you definitely didn't get the drive
why are you sharing prices rising i mean
not recently
you know you should have said that more
confidence
confidence in delivery by the way 12 of
you attacked me
that night when alex pulled up his tesla
oh i killed him
you guys killed him oh what happened no
no you don't remember like
y'all were just making fun of him and uh
y'all were just [ __ ] killing him
and then it was you my girl maybe it was
mark there
so [ __ ] weird i don't know i don't i
don't think i was oh i was i was just
killing his tesla and then my girl
called me over she's like we're ganging
up on dove
[Laughter]
and then you were just trashing it for
not having to drive by yourself or any
of
that
[ __ ] yeah you got a silent honda right
come on bro sorry sorry i had to i had
to land the final blow son
what was it i'm not telling you again
you don't deserve it you don't deserve
it bro you know what it was it
was it's your old tesla yeah this [ __ ]
is fine or what it's so great dude
uh-huh i love this car i'm so happy you
see
driving that tesla don't you want that
no he got driven don't you want that
to his uh to the ceremony yeah i had my
finance cousin driving me ladies
i like to see it all the way back took a
little nap [ __ ]
that was low-key a little sad when you
pulled up though you pulled up he was
like off in the corner he just turned
around and started walking away
still on it yeah the tesla
tesla oh [ __ ] i'm kind of cuz it's still
yours technically the title's in his
name
transfer hadn't happened yet it's taken
a couple of weeks i'm so happy
we're going to transfer out of you i'm
so happy you're people are charging in
new york
because i keep getting these like little
songs i'm happy you have no one hey hey
hey hey
i'm still happy of noah in this world
thank you dove
thank you for that who's going to be
with dove on his deathbed you think when
he dies
he'll be alone dude just him and some
tesla shares
that's where you're going with the
testosterone to the moon
all right do we care about these
billionaire [ __ ] going to [ __ ] space
it's embarrassing that's all flex why
can't we talk about that being here now
because it's embarrassing because you're
in second place and now you're trying to
get first on some [ __ ] you
really go you want to be there on a
technicality but like a [ __ ]
went to that same [ __ ] on a hot air
balloon like you don't even need a
spaceship you need hot air
literally if you got a balloon you could
go just as far david blaine done did
this already
yeah bro like your [ __ ] is stupid that
virgin what is his name
richard he sucks he's not a virgin but
that guy has tons of sex no i know
but uh he sucks you like he's a [ __ ]
bro
he's no no that guy is a hydra loser
yeah he's a [ __ ] loser
i'm gonna go to the top of space before
you but you did it on some technicality
[ __ ]
it's like if drake didn't rent out
dodger stadium he ran out of like the
anaheim angels
you know what i mean like go for the
real [ __ ] go to space or don't what
doesn't talk
about say what what is space orbit what
is consent
no no but like yeah be out of here be
out of here bro yeah bro go to space
right they were floating that's why
andrew can back them
the hover machine right yeah what's that
[ __ ] called
hot air balloon no oh indoors
indoor skydiving oh yeah that was it
that was it
when you want a hot air balloon you can
float it's not that hard bro floating is
not that hard
something they've been doing that [ __ ]
in turkey with like a hundred of them
exactly richard branson is a [ __ ]
dude and i mean that sincere oh yeah
that i didn't hate him until that now
like this is so whack
because you're in second diet inside i
hate it because it's just like
a list of people that like i want us to
get invited to nicaragua
hey yo you're such a facebook [ __ ] yeah
as dumb as this
he i know
hey hey andrew i got a call scheduled at
1 30 with this lady she gets you into
epsteen island very important
great procedure yeah we can get some
seed money
no but i will back up andrew because he
did turn down being able to shoot at the
brooklyn nets
arena uh the special
because he's like it's not msg not
having it's not doing that we can't do
it they would've spent a lot
of money to do it i'd have done it but
respect you for not doing it
we gotta do it automatic branson that
[ __ ] for sure
but floating in barclays does not have a
sour taste in your mouth about branson
at all
i don't like it no i don't like it
because you were losing so just
let this guy let this guy beat you
instead of like
kind of trying to beat him and then
pounding your chest i got there first no
you didn't
yeah you just said [ __ ] sore loser
yeah but he's been doing the virgin
galactic [ __ ] for a while
[Laughter]
he did it one of his test pilots died
no nothing annoyed me that when i have a
point and somebody shits on it right
away
no he's been doing that mark really
likes this guy why do you like this guy
when i'll be talking to my girl like
suggesting [ __ ] at the wedding like
before i say anything i have to be like
just hear me out
think about how it could potentially be
good because no matter what i suggest
it's wrong
yeah yeah you gotta suggest the wrong
[ __ ] that way she goes back at you and
then picks the what you actually want
that's that'd be a smarter way to do it
sometimes i'll be getting excited about
my ideas my ideas are fire
this is one idea you're doing the sword
that's one thing you said you're going
to do
definitely swords uh no no this was one
idea no i don't want to give away my
wedding [ __ ] yeah i mean
have these [ __ ] try to copy me
so if richard branson could get married
two months before france is gonna be
getting married right at my [ __ ]
destination too
you get married aren't we so pissed dude
[ __ ] that
dude what a [ __ ] my whole life i dream
of a baby
i'm a big boy and i'll come to space as
a big boy
hey what could you dream of
like if you've got a
nothing good happening on the island
nothing legal happening why do you need
to separate yourself from the wrestling
your own country come on baby
[Music]
something a little suspicious
i mean johnny depp was beating the dog
[ __ ] out of his wife on an island wasn't
he
he was raping her but he was beating the
dog [ __ ]
oliver
come on right right yeah
or wrong son you just go up to that
island
dog [ __ ] all over that
yo you got a bastard hound or something
like that why is so much
dog [ __ ] on this goddamn island bruh oh
my god
johnny depp was there yeah if you have
an island it's us
yo if you got an island your suspect at
the very least
and watching him [ __ ] rape the space
race like that he a rapist dog
there you go i don't like that he bugged
bezos i'll be honest that's what i like
about it
bazel sucks too basil [ __ ] about it
i love it i love that they're all
bitching at each other and then branson
goes oh yeah no i'll go space no but
elon been one he just beat him
ben had rockets yo yeah he's gonna first
he didn't go he's scared yeah he is
[ __ ]
elon is [ __ ] that's fine but he don't
care he's not beating his chest about
i was first in space hold on you don't
sound like [ __ ] glad richard branson
didn't say that he was just up there he
was like he was
saying when he was a boy that's all he
wanted when i was a weezer
why was a weird little boy growing up in
very
well i was so excited
i got help in the and then we went up
there
and i brought exactly nobody from my
life but scientists because all i care
about is me
i will say the fact that he wrote that
[ __ ] trapped up marked
so instead i put my broom on my head and
the hell out of it
if he ripped it i'd be like all right
but the fact that he wrote i was like
that's what you wrote down
that was your essay what would the next
generation of rapists do with their
billions
like you can literally make kids not
poor anymore yeah there's some people
they get too much space in their
stomachs
yeah you're doing